gunman who tried to assassinate her for
being an outspoken supporter of
education for girls she was 15 years old
during this next event hosted by
politics and pro's bookstore ms
youssef's eye was interviewed along with
her father by michelle martin of npr
this is about an hour
[Music]
this is someone this is breaking the
quaker tradition and respect for science
but i want to start by quoting a very
smart journalist friend of mine anand
girdardas who said that in this country
we have it all wrong we stand up for
judges but we sit for teachers
let me say that again we stand up for
judges but we sit for teachers so i'd
like to
and if you think about it if they do
their jobs properly we are it's less
likely that we will need those judges
correct so if you don't mind zeodine and
i
include you in this if you don't mind i
would ask if the educators here would
stand so that we may honor you properly
for the work that you do
and tom i want to be sure you were
properly recognized the head of school
here the head of my children's school is
here along with two of her colleagues
karen aaron and monet i don't know why
you're hiding but
we're glad you're here so what that
being said welcome to you both we are so
very happy to see you
and you are probably very happy to be
seen right
i cannot forget that it was a week a
year ago this week a year ago this week
that these terrible events occurred
it seems like a long time ago does it
does it not or does it
um
i don't feel really that something had
has happened to me
when i think of malala i just
in my mind there are some pictures in
which a girl is lying on a stretcher and
her forehead is bleeding her ears
bleeding i don't think that's me
because i am feeling that
i'm just a normal
girl and i'm feeling now
really powerful and courageous because
after that incident
the the prayers of people and the
and the good wishes of people and the
card and the teddy bears that people
have sent me
[Music]
and their prayers that had made me more
powerful
so
i'm really happy now and i don't feel
like as if i was shot once
one of the things that i learned from
your book which is which is is uh is
wonderful by the way if i may recommend
it um
is that this is really a family story
this is a story and a sacrifice
that was made by all of you in the
family so malala i'm going to start by
asking you what do you most admire about
your father
first of all i'm thankful to him because
he and my mother gave me birth
and
he's a great father
and
i'm inspired by him because
because the work he was doing at that
time when terrorism was spreading in
swath
at that time it was not easy to speak
the people who spoke
were slaughtered on the next day
the people who raised their voice
were flogged on the next day
more than 400 schools were blasted
it was really hard to speak at that time
and my father did
and i got inspired
by him and that's why i said that i will
also speak up for my rights and i'll
also speak up for the rights of every
girl to get education and to go to
school
see odin what do you must admire about
malala
it's a difficult question
[Laughter]
i think
malala
is an average girl but
there are something which is
extraordinary about her
she never agrees with me
and
she always jokes and
she's very humorous
now a bit tired and serious i don't know
why
because she worked
she had so many meetings all this day
one special uh quality which she has
that she doesn't commit a mistake again
i mean she if she has made any mistake
in life that as for once
so she doesn't repeat her mistakes
and she's very respectful to her
teachers to her elders
call with brothers
and
she's a good girl
i love
i i do want to ask you dude what it does
start with you what you as as alyssa
mentioned you ran a girls school
in in pakistan with that malala you
attended and i have to ask what gave you
this passion for girls education because
i think that it's one thing when you are
the person
who is on the bottom to want to rise but
it's another when you are on the top and
to want to share the privileges that you
had as a man and as the head of a
household so where did you get your
passion for girls education
basically i was born in a society where
girls are ignored
i mean that only in our society in all
developing and poor countries
even in developed countries
women are not given that status when
much
which men have seen centuries
right from the very beginning i was very
sensitive to this kind of discrimination
and
i was born in the house of
cleric my father was
a mawlana
he
uh
used to lead prayers in the mosque he
was a great speaker
but he was
broad-minded
and he was very progressive as well
and
he
also taught me
many things
and i learned from him so many things
but in the same
home i had
five sisters
and none of them got education
and
till my high school
i could not see any girl in my
in my school in my classroom so you can
imagine that girl's education was
not at all there i mean
uh so in such a society or in such a
situation i was very sensitive to all
this discrimination especially towards
girls
for example in the morning time when i
was used to entertain with the
milk and cream
and my sisters were given only tea
so i used to take that but i felt that
this kind of discrimination
later on when i got mature so i became
more sensitive to all these
discriminations and when
she was born
and i became very much sensitive towards
girls towards women discrimination
and i wrote poems about them
that
boys and girls
women and men they are equal
and i think that
this simple
biological difference between the men
and women
should not be the best of the political
and social discrimination
so
that's kind of thinking which made a
difference and i usually tell people i'm
asked
often that what special training have
you given to your daughter
so i usually tell people
that
you should not ask me what i have done
rather you ask me what i did not do
which is usually done by parents
i did not clip her wings to fly
i did not stop her from flying
and all girls like her they are mean for
stars
they can fly
and i always give a message to the
parents all around the world where girls
are suffering
that trust your daughters
they are faithful
honor your daughters they are honorable
and educate your daughters
they are amazing
[Music]
malala one of the things that i have
heard you say
which has not gotten a lot of attention
in fact you said this at the united
nations when you spoke there earlier
this year is that you are not just
fighting for the rights of girls to get
education you are also fighting for the
rights of boys to get education
including
the children of the terrorists and i'd
like to ask you to tell us more about
that why do you feel that way
there has been a discrimination in our
society
and men have been doing this for
centuries
but this time
we women are going to bring change
we are speaking up
for girls rights but we must not behave
like men you must not behave like
like they have done in the past we must
believe in equality
and we must take each decision with
justice so that's why
we not only speak about girls rights
but we also speak about boys rights
because in many countries
they cannot go to school because of
child labor they have to earn for their
families
their only job is to is to earn
so i think
we also need to speak up for them
because tomorrow maybe girls would be
going to school but there will be so
many boys that who will be out of school
so if you want to bring a change then we
must do it with justice
see one of the other things that i
learned from your book which i'm not
sure that everyone
fully understands is that you your
family was under threat for a very long
time this is not something that just
happened overnight this is not something
that happened in a day or a week it was
really
years that you feared for your safety
and for your family's safety that you
were being threatened for a very very
long time and i think a lot of people
would be interested to know how you
sustained yourself
through that period how did you keep
going
yes of course uh i was on taliban's
radar for the long times for the last
three four years i can say
because and that this was not only me
because in swath in khebar
especially
hundreds of opinion leaders
hundreds of elders notables have been
killed they have been assassinated
and i was one of them
and i took care
in my own way but i didn't have any
security
but one has to leave
i mean
there is no option
uh
that
when she was
targeted just 10 months before
when she got femme that very year in
2012
after her fame she was
i mean
they issued
a warning that
as she is
speaking against
us and
we
will not tolerate it
and we will kill her not only her but
they also included one other social
activist
may she live long she's still alive
and they came up but we thought that
even terrorists might have some
ethics
because they destroyed some 1500 schools
but they never injured a child
and she was a child
and we and we thought it was our
i mean misunderstanding that they will
not come for a child
so i was
uh
i mean
the they would be target not her
but since i mean one year
we were thinking about this too that she
may be targeted but there was no option
we had to live in that valley
and uh we had to
fight for our rights
well but some people could have said
well it's just too dangerous i could
close the school i mean some of the the
the fascinating details were at the time
when for example you took the girls on a
field trip do you remember to the
mountains yeah exactly just to see the
yeah just to see the the river and the
and that you got a nasty letter saying
what is this with taking these girls
you're doing immoral improper things and
you took them to see you said you have
the right to see the water and the
mountains just like the boys do did you
ever think maybe i should close my
school maybe it's too hard
i think uh this uh kind of
fundamentalism our
radicalization came
in the past four five years
in swath we had a very peaceful
very
uh a society which had a great harmony
and diversity
and we have a famous verse uh in our
language
which i'll speak in pashto yarmi hindus
it's in the book
it means that my friend is a hindu and
i'm a muslim
and to love and to respect my hindu
friend
i sweep in the temple
i mean it was the kind of love for the
it was interfaith harmony
all this happened after the cold
war
when swet union attacked afghanistan and
our establishment and your country's
establishment well the war against the
the swede
so
i mean
from that
in in in 80s early 80s
this fundamentalism and
radicalization started
and
it is
not the story of one day
this radicalization has been brought
since long
and even i'll tell you that in the books
of the afghan schools
they used to be taught that two plus two
clash and courts is equal to four clash
and corpse
they used to be taught that if there are
20
soldiers of the sweet army and you kill
10
how will how many will be
so these were the questions of addition
and subtraction
so if you ridiculize a generation
and you
jihadise them
for your own west interests
and when states are involved
so this is the end
that then the peaceful citizens of that
land like us
they lose
the the the right to live were there
so this is a long story
it is malala do you mind if i ask you
you say
freely in the book that you were afraid
there were days that you would lock the
doors at night after everyone else had
gone to bed i don't know if anyone else
kind of knew that this is what you were
doing until the book came out i wanted
to ask though how did you keep going
what made you keep going
you know they say that courage is not
the absence of fear it's what you do
when you are afraid
but how did you
sustain yourself
i think when there is darkness
and when it's night we all are afraid at
that time
but when we sleep we wait for the
morning and we are hopeful that we will
see the light of the day
when we will open our eyes so i was
always hopeful
and i was worried as well because i knew
that the taliban can come to our house
they can do anything i used to lock the
doors i used to see everything in our
house then i used to say ayatul kursi
that's the worst from quran three times
to protect our house but then i say
if i only protect my house what about
the street what about the school
building so then i used to add two more
horses
and then i used to say like what about
the pakistani about the world and then i
used to say it more and more and more so
then i used to protect the whole
world from any attack or from any home
blast
so
i did what i could do and i was worried
about my father at that time but i was
hopeful
and
and still
i think that
it was my responsibility to speak up for
my rights and to speak up for the rights
of every girl and it is still my
responsibility to speak up for the
rights of every child do you think
you're making a difference
when i look at the response of people
when i look at the love and the support
of people then i think
that we are going to make a great change
first no one could raise the banner that
we are against the taliban no one could
say that shame on you the taliban but
now people can
they are only known by the terrorists
now people call them the taliban so it's
a great example that now people dare to
speak they are not afraid of the
terrorists
and i'm hopeful
that a day will come
that we will see every child to go to
school most of the time i am related to
the taliban
but i want education and when i talk
about education not only talibanization
not only terrorism
is a hurdle between the way of
education but there are many issues as
well
that we must keep in mind
that is poverty
children are suffering from child labor
they have to earn for their family they
are suffering from child trafficking
they are being they are being used for
earning money by some people by some
robbers
there are cultural norms and traditions
that stop children from going to their
school
in our society
i'm proud to be a person because we are
famous for our hospitality we are famous
for our bravery we are famous for our
courage but still
there are some norms in our culture
that does not give
equal rights to girls
so there are many difficulties
for children to go to school not only
terrorism
so i think we must fight all these
issues and the best way to fight these
issues
is educate those children
forgive me for for making a joke but
speaking of child labor you're working
very hard these days
i mean
i understand they have you going from
like pillar to post and from place to
place you've been on quite a quite a
quite are you having any fun at all
it's a very nice question
and i miss those days but
dad
now that is fine that is quite good
um
the first thing is that outside of my
home i look like a very obedient a very
serious a very good kind of girl but
nobody knows what happened inside the
house
so
inside the house i was quite
well
it does not mean that i was naughty my
brothers used to fight with me and then
i had to give them a response
of course i mean
of course yes so that's like
i have um
some rights to justify myself now and
so that's why uh yeah like it's good to
fight with your brothers and it's good
to teach them to give them advices and
my little brother he's
nine years old and
i fight with him because i'm thinking
about his future
okay
he he wants he wants ipad he wants ipod
uh so he wants to play games and i think
that is not good for his future and in
response he cries and he shouts to me
and he says you can forgive the thali
but you are not forgiving me
so
that's what is happening in our house
already we are busy so he's not sorry
you're on a book tour now he's got your
ipad that's where you know they don't
even ask about me
not at all
i think it's the fifth or sixth day that
i'm here in america and they didn't ask
about me
that's because they've got your ipad
what was your favorite template
what did he say to you
why are you so famous he said
like they also don't know what i do why
do i go outside so
we both were sitting on a table and we
were having breakfast so he said malala
i said yes i can't understand why people
are giving you prizes
what did you say i couldn't answer i
said well
i'll make you understand later
because he said i cannot understand
everywhere you go people say like this
is malala and they give you a word what
have you done
so he still needs to understand just my
annoying sister who won't give me my
ipad yeah well i understand that there's
a bit of a friendly competition between
you two about who is to be prime
minister and who is to be the secretary
who's winning that one
the the my brother in the middle uh my
both of my brothers are younger than me
so my brother in the middle he is he
doesn't speak a lot he just plays on
xbox that's his job
i think uh you know i know that it's not
for like under 18 the games he play but
and
the little brother he is
like
i hope there's no lawyer here so he's
like a lawyer let me text oh no there's
no lawyers here
he's like a lawyer
whenever i fight with him he can just
change the style of his talking he can
just change his emotions and he can just
like i would feeling i then i feel
guilty was i really hard upon him was i
really cruel
and like he just makes me feel that
and so that's why it's really hard to
live with them
[Laughter]
what was your favorite subject in school
my favorite subject is the one in which
i'm
like
weak
i like physics
and i love physics because physics is
all about truth it tells you about the
laws about the principle and that the
whole universe is obeying and it
explains
great things big thing the thing that we
cannot even understand in two three
letters like f is equal to m a w is
equal to m d it's hard to understand i i
can't q and you see all the mtr people
are going
there's nobody from science friday here
they're going what is she talking what
we're all words people we're sorry just
like we'll catch up we'll catch up just
keep yeah
i like physics i thought you were weak
in math though you thought you were
saying that was your worst subject no
did i get that wrong um like i'm not
that much good in calculations um
but still i work hard and i love english
uh literature i love english grammar and
i also love other all other subject i'm
also taking interest in history
and
so but physics i like it i don't know
why
i understand that you had a friendly
competition with the other two girls in
your class
are you worried that they're getting
ahead of you now that you're on book
tour
yeah you were like was it moniba and you
were like first second
yeah first second and third she called
me when i was in birmingham
and uh we used to have like uh she was
my rival and we used to fight a lot who
will get the top position who will get
the high marks
and when i called han we both were
talking i asked her like how are you
feeling you are getting the top position
i'm no more at this school and she says
now i don't enjoy my my competition with
anyone now i don't enjoy my school now i
don't enjoy my exams even and if i now
i'm getting first position but it does
not give me like that much i don't i'm
not feeling that much proud that i used
to when i
like when she
beat me
because when i was in when i was in
school i used to get first position in
my class and i thought that i will be
getting first position forever i didn't
know that there are many other girls who
can defeat me who can get higher marks
than me
and it's a concept that we usually have
we
we don't think that we need to continue
the hard work
to remain on that position
and when she came to our school i said
like i have beaten all the girls and it
doesn't matter but
when she came she got the top marks and
i got the second position in the class
and at that time i realized that if you
want to be at the same position then
work hard and
like don't consider that you will always
get the top position
and also
like
be ready
or anything
i think you'd fit in very well here
who do you admire so many people here
admire you who do you
admire i admire everyone
because
i think everyone is
taking a part in this society in
bringing a change i admire all the
teachers because they're teaching
students they're they're they're making
the future generation they're building
the future i admire students as well
because they're learning and they're
also
because we are working today it seemed
that it's just a normal life and
today i went to school i taught students
so but this is also
it means that you are building future
when you are educating those students
so i admire everyone and especially
those people who are thinking about
changing society who are thinking about
the rights of girls and the rights of
boys as well
and who are thinking about peace in
suffering countries like syria like
pakistan like afghanistan do you want to
go back home
yes of course because how can one forget
his home and i love pakistan and i miss
pakistan
and
i'm hopeful i'm hopeful that i will go
back to pakistan as soon as possible but
i want to go back there
i want to go back there but first i need
to empower myself
i need to empower myself with knowledge
with education and i need to study hard
i need to work hard and when i would be
empowered when i would be powerful
then i'll go back to pakistan inshallah
[Applause]
[Music]
do you think that might be possible do
you want to go home too do you think you
will be able to it's a difficult
question
i i think personally as she said
she has to learn a lot and she has a
long way to go
and um
for me i will go back uh when the
situation is a bit normal
these days
uh i think
quite dangerous for me as well as for
her
so we will go back
um
the love of one's own home on own land
i think it's
a kind of feeling
which comes when you
live your land
it's very difficult
you remember each and everything
of your homeland which you
live behind
i miss the shiny faces of my students
where i used to go every morning
i used to go from classroom to classroom
and see the shining
the brilliant faces of the boys and
girls
and i'm listening in these developed
countries
i'm needed in pakistan i'm reading
needed in afghanistan
i'm needed in swahili
where
i should contribute to education to
girls education to boys education
and i think that
i believe that one should live for a
cause which is greater than him
so my cause is greater than me even if i
die
i will continue my campaign
but at least i will not put her life at
stake
that's clear
the taliban say they would still like to
kill her
they said even recently this week that
they put out another communication
saying that they would still like to do
it
i think they just reminded me it
remember
uh the thing is that
i have already seen death
and i know that death is supporting me
in my cause of education
death does not want to kill me
and first
before this attack i might have been a
little bit afraid how death would be now
i'm not because i have experienced it so
they cannot make me stop to continue my
campaign
now
i'm feeling more powerful more
courageous and when i look at the
support of people
then i think they can never stop me and
we we will continue our struggle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i understand that we do have questions
from the audience which i would like to
share with you so i'll
i will ask some of the questions from
the audience that were sending how are
they sending via email or how are they
sent by facebook and things of that
things of that sort sent in in different
ways and then i'm going to
cut off the questions a few minutes
early just in case you had a closing
thought that you wanted to give us a
closing idea
maybe a charge maybe you want to give us
homework maybe there's something we
should do
to be
helpful to you so we'll do that at the
end so the questions i have a few let's
see i have a question do you want me to
say the names or no
no it's okay okay so one question i have
is your work so far has been nothing
less than incredible your brother would
disagree but um but but what's next for
you do you plan on continuing to help
girls around the world are you
considering other paths we look forward
to seeing what you become and we thank
you for what you've achieved what what
is your dream i would like to know what
is next for you you want to go to
university i assume and yes yeah
i'm still in all levels
the thing is that i simply say i want to
work for education but how
so i want to start it from now
and we have set up malala fund
malala fund has three objectives
the first one is advocacy we need to ask
we need to ask those responsible leaders
those responsible politicians to work
for education and to make it their top
priority
we also need to work on the ground
we need to build schools we need to do
teachers training we need to do seminars
to motivate parents
to let their children to go to school
and then we also need to recognize
those girls who are raising their voice
so we are going to give them award
to give them a platform to speak
globally
and then
in future
i want to become a politician
[Music]
[Applause]
well you know i understand that you
started your way i have to i have to
read this i hope you started your
vocation early because you said that
when it was exam time do you want to
read that part did you want to say that
part of course where you uh where is it
i've marked it
i had marked it well you said that you'd
start your exams by saying
what to your teacher do you remember
that part you said
uh yeah yeah you remember that okay
yeah one of my teachers
uh
whenever there was like a viva he used
to ask questions i said you are the best
teacher ever i have seen in my life
that was a great trick students
learn from it
praise your teacher when they are having
exam and they are having a test and they
are asking you questions so it's really
effective
all right good advice
okay
another question is what what inner
qualities made it possible for you to
exhibit such courage and self-confidence
what inner inner qualities i don't know
if you
feel it's it's that way but that's the
question what inner qualities do you
think made it possible for you to
exhibit such courage
i think i'm just listening to my heart
and my heart is just listening to people
and
i'm looking
because i can see those children who are
suffering from child labor
i can see i i can remember the time when
you were suffering from terrorism
i can remember those days
when it was hard you went to sleep
because after 10 minutes we would hear
the noise of a bomb blast
i remember that time
so
that's why
i think heart is really kind to everyone
and that's why it told me
to speak
i think that malala
this is a big question that
during malignancy and terrorism
hundreds and thousands of people have
been killed
children have been killed
even when
drone attacks uh target the terrorists
some children and anderson people are
killed there
why are stories different sometimes i
think
and
to be honest
i learn from her
when it comes to the purity of heart
when it comes to the purity of intention
and this is the thing
which spread all around the world
the purity of her heart the
purity of her faith the purity of her
intention
because in history
really things concer
coincide with time and with people
so
this is my feeling
that
and
she doesn't do it for
fame or for reputation or for big name
one day when she was in hospital
and
my friend gave me a clip of video
and told me
that please you show this video clip to
your daughter she will be very happy
it was by jew news
there
and
the headline of that news was
it was some
forum thinkers forum uh
assessment
and they had the news that barack obama
was seven and malala is on sixth
it was kind of
for me it was kind of joke but
and it was a headline
and
when i just showed and she was still in
hospital and i was
as a father i wanted to make her more
and more happy somehow
so when i showed her the clip that i
have good news for you you just watch it
and when she watched that
i was expecting that she would be
excited
i asked her how do you feel you are six
and the president of america is on seven
she told me okay abba she calls me abba
okay but i don't like such
categorization of human beings
so i learned that this is quite
different things before this nobel peace
prize
announcement
her doctor dr fiona
who has been mentioned in the book when
she was nominated
she came to her home and
she was very excited as a doctor of her
and she told her malala do you know
you have been nominated for the nobel
peace prize
you want it
you love you like it and she simply said
i need peace
this was first response
and that's why when the news came she
was very composed
very poised
were you disappointed i i feel
weaker than her billionaires so many
things you were sad huh and i i'm happy
that she's stronger
were you disappointed
at the announcement the rule that i have
in my life to follow
is that
always
be hopeful
but don't have great expectations
and that's why i'm hopeful
that's why i'm hopeful but i don't have
like great expectations
and
i was ready i told myself that malala be
ready anything can happen not only nobel
peace prize anything can happen in your
life
people might support you some people may
turn against you it might become
difficult in your life to continue your
campaign you must be ready for it
because life will never be the same
changes will come in your life now you
are
under 18 that's why many people are
supporting you but tomorrow if you join
a party half of the population will be
against
so that i have prepared myself for that
and being a politician you must keep it
in mind what you say
and other than that if i talk about
winning the nobel peace prize or not
winning the nobel peace prize
i i think i have i have won the nobel
peace prize because when i look at the
nomination and the support of people if
you just remove the jury
i
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a question which i think could
have come from many many people in this
room and the question is i work with
teenagers what kinds of positive words
can you give them
during their struggles with friends
family and school work
i think the first thing is that
when we are alone when
when we are just one person then
our voice does not have that impact
when we
when we are together when we are united
then we become then we become more
powerful
and that's what i have learned you must
work together
you must be kind to each other you must
tolerate each other as well because
sometimes we don't even tolerate each
other we don't
tolerate each other's language each
other's culture
each other's religion
so that is really necessary for
continuing your mission in your life
that tolerate each other
and respect is also very necessary
even i respect the taliban i cannot use
any bad word for them
so respect is really necessary
and i think that these words are really
simple in life respect love
friendship kindness tolerance patience
seems very easy
but it's hard to bring it into your life
so i think
if these few words come into your life
then i think your future and
your
then you become successful in your
mission
is there anything about the uh this
country about england that's different
than you thought it would be
well so many things are different
the first thing is that
most of the girls and women are accepted
with equal rights
they are free to walk on the roadside
for us these are equal rights because we
have seen a more difficult situation
than the situation in uk
girls can go outside they have their
right to choose they have the right to
make a choice they
they're they're just they have given the
same rights as boys have
other than that our school
is also totally different the way that
we are taught
in our schools our schools are quite
good in pakistan
but
children are not taught skills
but in uk
i was also learning about painting about
music
about exercises about pee
about haiti and that i didn't like i
never liked to go to the kitchen
so that's why i had to learn that as
well
now in uk so
i think there are there are many changes
in both these societies and the best
thing and the thing that i like
in uk is that they
accept others people culture and their
religion and their traditions
now i'm wearing shalvarkamis in uk and
they have accepted it
and i have accepted their way of wearing
dresses their way of speaking their way
of having communication and that's what
we need
in our countries and in our society it
is the acceptance of each other's
traditions each other's religion each
other's culture so i think that is very
necessary
speaking of religion uh one person
wanted to know
how you feel about your religion and how
people use it as an excuse for conflict
and violence it's a very good question
because whenever
it's really
sad to say that whenever a muslim person
does a crime or do a bomb blast on media
you can hear they say like a muslim
terrorist but when
a person who is not muslim when he does
it then they said only terrorist
and the example is oklahoma because
nobody mentioned the religion but now
people are saying muslim terrorists
so the thing is
that islam
is a religion of peace is a religion of
humanity is a religion of brotherhood
the taliban only know about jihad and
about just fighting i think they haven't
read the quran yet they haven't they
haven't studied it yet
right i agree
you know it's interesting because i
think that people
i think sometimes people
on our side of the world aren't sure how
they're supposed to feel about the
taliban in that they hate what they do
but sometimes they feel that they are
part of the culture say
almost like a political party with very
extreme views and they're not sure if
they're allowed to have an opinion about
it do you see my my question it's almost
as if they feel that well
this is the culture
it's not our business
can you speak to that
please
the question is that i think there are
some people who aren't sure
if they're allowed to criticize the
taliban if they're allowed to feel that
it's wrong
does that make sense because they feel
that well
maybe we don't agree
but if it's part of the culture then how
who are we to
have opinions about it i understand that
i would like to tell everyone that the
taliban they are pashtuns
they are muslims
some of them are pakistani some of them
are from afghanistan but it does not
mean
that all muslims are terrorists it does
not mean that all pakistani are
terrorists it does not mean that all
pashtuns are terrorists it's true that
the terrorists might be muslims
but it's not true that muslims are
terrorists so you must keep it in mind
and when it comes to traditions i think
they are not we don't consider them to
be a part of our culture
because in our culture in pashtun
culture
you must respect woman you must respect
her
and the taliban doesn't do it and not
only taliban these are different groups
you only know the name of the taliban
you must call them terrorist groups
because
you only know about one word but there
are many other groups as well
so they if they were muslims they would
have kept in mind the hadith of prophet
peace be upon him
that it's the duty of every muslim
every person whether man or woman to get
knowledge to get education
and they have forgotten it
they don't know it
so i think
and i want to tell everyone
that these people
are not what we are
they are just they just want their own
ideas they want their own
they want their own demands
and i think
if taliban or if any other terrorist
group wants to rule over the country
then we have a way of democracy
stand for election
show us what do you want what are your
objectives
if we people like it
if the common people like it if public
like it
then they will vote you
if you deserve it
so i think the decision must be made by
people and we must remind the taliban
and every other terrorist group and in
islam we are taught that you must listen
to everyone in your society and you must
not divide your society on the basis of
religion
and i think
simply to say
that these terrorists need to study
quran and hadees and they need to study
about islam and they need to sit again
and go to madrasa or a school
school is necessary
they must go to a school and they'll
learn they must learn about islam
do you have do you have hope that groups
like the taliban can be brought into
dialogue with people that they will be
persuaded that education that democracy
is the is the way
to advance their ideas or to advance
ideas do you do you have hope that
that their reign of terror will end yes
i
have hope this is very political kind of
question
and to speak honestly
to tame taliban
or to
bring them to justice
it needs a political will
and it needs uh
clarity of the policy
i mean i feel that in my part of the
world in our region
terrorism
talibanization has become the part of
the regional and global politics
this issue could be resolved very easily
if the states
in that region
and the most powerful state where we are
now
if they decide that we have to resolve
this issue and we will not seek interest
under the height of this issue
you might have heard about the good
taliban in bad taliban do you know good
taliban no no we want to hear about this
interesting like good cholesterol and
bad cholesterol yeah
the taliban who are killing people in
afghanistan
for many people in pakistan they are
good taliban
and the taliban who are killing people
in pakistan
in portugal
they are
they may be very good taliban for
some of
people in your establishment and in
afghanistan
so this is very difficult situation
and this is very horrible
and whatever is done
it is
to keep them and maintain it there
for the political reasons for the
political waste interest
for the strategic reasons
and i request these world powers
regional powers that you have had enough
politics
for the
for the manipulation of for the
to plunder the resources of each other
to have strategic hegemonies in each
other's regions
now let's do politics for people
now let's do politics for clean water
now let's do politics for
food
now let's do politics for
health and education
so if they decide
believe me this will be resolved in a
month
the problem the problem lies with the
political leadership
and i will not blame any one country
everybody is thief in his heart
and
the the the the view which is shaped
here in the west
that is i respect media but that is made
by media
and which is shaped in the east in
pakistan that is associated by the media
we came here to this country this is my
fourth time believe me the love of these
american people is a great nation
it's a great nation
the love of the people for us
when i see in the eyes of the people i
think
this should be the most lovable nation
on the earth
then why my people hate them
for example
these are our political things
and i requested this forum these are
very bright people here teachers
students
opinion leaders
that we must put pressure on our
garments i should put pressure on my
government
and my state you should put pressure on
your state
that why a huge amount of the taxpayers
is
spent on arms ammunitions
why
and that was what she said
i will quote my daughter she should
quote me by the way but
well
they'd send
pins
not guns
send
books not tanks
and the most beautiful thing sin
teachers not soldiers
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
well that is is
where we had hoped to end i was going to
ask if you each had some closing
thoughts that you would leave us with if
you had
ziaudine you actually started us off i
wanted to ask if you have any assignment
for us is there something you would wish
to do i'm very thankful and i greatly
appreciate
the quietness of the quakers i mean
it has its own voice
i i love it please
malala do you have a final thought for
us and thank you again let me say on
behalf of all of us here on behalf of
this fine institution on behalf of all
of our guests on behalf of politics and
prose all of your friends and they are
all your friends here thank you so much
for coming do you have a final thought
to all of you because you are sitting
here you're listening to me and you are
also listening to the cause of education
and that is really important for me
because i speak for education of every
child in every corner of the world and
the thing that i noticed here when i
came to uk for the second time i think
two three weeks ago from america to
america to america
sorry
sorry when i came here to america and
there was
in our meetings we had in our schedule
we had written that malala would go to a
school
and that school is just
few kilometers away from those tall
buildings of new york and when i went
there and when girls told me their
stories at how hard
it is for them to get education even in
new york even in america
because of poverty because of the
concepts of the family because of the
hardship they face
so i think
we also need to work here as well
[Applause]
but the
but good thing but good thing about this
country is that they have provided
schools to every students now we need
to motivate children now we need to
motivate all the girls and in countries
like syria like egypt
like nigeria and afghanistan then we
need to start from building up schools
and trying to motivate the parents try
to help the teachers and try to
we need to work from every aspect if you
want a bright future so i think it's
really hard to say it through worlds but
um
like it feels
very easy when i say let's work let's
work let's work
but
i think let's do it let's really do it
[Music]
malala
you've both had a very long day you have
a very long day tomorrow i understand
you had some
nice visits with maybe some nice people
today that
some people here know rather well
but i'm sure you're very tired we want
to thank you very much so very much for
what you've done for what you will do
thank you both so much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
book tv is